foreign
[Music]
so I noticed that when you talk to
people about the corona years it you
know some people tend they start to talk
about a novel they read in the beginning
of the pandemic and somehow that book
ended up mediating their experience of
the whole time do you have a book of
that kind well I I wrote one so I think
that was how I got through it
um and in fact I
I tend to have a
slightly fencing relationship with
reading when I'm writing and because my
periods of writing are intense and short
and interspersed with long periods of
not writing
um I sort of keep those activities
separate but yes for me and in fact
so strangely
um I conceived of this book
in the period before
um
uh life stopped and in fact the basis of
the book
I I wanted it to take place in a in a
suspended in a in a world where reality
had been suspended in some way and
um you know that was what I had started
sort of crafting and putting down and
and then I was sort of looking almost
looking out of my window thinking hang
on a minute you know the same thing is
happening out there so it was an odd
um and because second place is
a book based on a book by a woman who
Mabel Dodge who wrote a book about her
time when D.H Lawrence visited her and
stayed with her in New Mexico and before
we start talking about the book I mean
can you say something about I mean D.H
Lawrence he's always such a presence in
your writing and when I realized that
you now finally you know wrote a book
not completely about him but based on
him I was so thrilled but why is he such
an important writer to you
um I think he well I think he's an
important writer to a lot of
women writers
um kind of in spite of oneself uh
because he's also a hate figure for a
lot of feminists and
um so he's a strange mentor to have
um that he uh
the fact that he he came from
um a working class background which you
know is an unusual thing in English
literature
um he his
language his sentence structures uh the
way that that his sentences travel in in
completely unexpected directions
um kind of proves to a person
not wanting to write
the available male sentence it proves
that there there is another kind of
sentence
um he he doesn't write with the voice of
patriarchy and
um that's something that that
yeah numerous women have thought okay
it's not quite that he's an honorary
woman but but his experience of being
um of of sort of low status in in terms
of male values
um gives gives a clue
to the possibilities I guess and how did
you come across it's quite extraordinary
this book Lorenzo and teos uh how did
you come across this
[Music]
um
I was thinking of writing something
about uh the idea of kind of artistic
Utopias and and places where people go
to to create and um this place
particularly had had
always interested me because some people
that I'm really interested in like
Lawrence and like the painter Marsden
Hartley had had gone and created there
and and
um so I was sort of curious about it and
anyway I've I've came I ordered this
book you know because I did a little
research and Mabel Dodge Luhan
um
was the the founder and patroness of
this
artist community and
um
so I ordered the book and as soon as I
read it or started reading it it was
um
yeah probably more of a kind of
Thunderbolt experience than that I've
had for a while because there were so
many
themes that were starting to kind of
mass around me
um in terms of giving a Clues to where I
was going to go and what was coming next
and um
it was hard to conceive of something of
that next step after the trilogy and and
um I was really wondering what kind of
form
these themes we're going to take and
um the idea of using
a disused book as it were the book was I
mean I think it is Art and print but
completely neglected and forgotten and
and so I had this thought that I would
um
go and live put my book inside this
disused book and that that would solve
so many problems about
the kind of location of of a novel
um and the Forum I mean and now you
mentioned the the trilogy because and
I'm just going to rewind a little bit
because you know this talk has been
postponed many times right we were
supposed to sit here a year ago on this
stage and you know things continued to
happen and and during that time three of
your books were published in Danish and
they basically span a period of 20 years
right from a life's work that came out
in 2001 and and up to this book and I
know that a lot of people sort of for
them it became the books that
accompanied them during this year and I
thought that tonight we could in a way
use these books as a kind of platform to
to to try to understand how you
developed your thinking about life and
literature and the relationship between
each other in the these years because I
think it's something quite extraordinary
about the way you write your your
writing life you could say that those
two are so closely connected so we will
return to second place but if we go back
to a life's work and maybe you could
actually start by reading a paragraph
just so everyone gets a sense of the
sound of the book
this is quite a uh
uncharacteristically gripping
um a bit of this book
um
sorry I shouldn't put my own book down
like that it's
just you'll understand it's hard from
this distance to go back into into this
reality
um a few days after my daughter's birth
I go to a concert
I bought the ticket weeks before not
expecting her to come so soon
I have difficulty walking because of my
scar and my grasp of the principles of
breastfeeding is still tentative but
nevertheless I am determined to go
during pregnancy I had plenty of time to
formulate stirring resolutions
concerning the maintenance in motherhood
of my Independence and interests
fervently imagining myself at parties
and Gala events skiing in the bundeswold
reclining in Mediterranean sunsets
sitting meditatively at my desk all the
while with the baby in a sort of cartoon
thought bubble above my head
this state of mind has extended briefly
into my daughter's life like a
projection of rock overhanging a cliff
my mother-in-law is to hand to assist
with the transaction and appears nervous
given that I am taking with me the
baby's only known source of comfort and
nourishment her resources should things
go wrong are limited
I scale down my plans and promised to
return during the interval
from the phone box halfway down the road
I receive hesitant but favorable reports
at the tube station too things appear to
be holding steady and I get on the train
as the stations pass I feel slightly
wild with a mounting sense of wrongdoing
as if I had stolen something and when I
arrive I hobble up the escalators and
fall upon the nearest telephone as if it
were an oxygen mask it's funny reading
this no mobile phones
when I get through the station foyer
immediately fills with the tinny
bleating sound of my daughter's cries
my mother-in-law's voice comes faintly
through the static and the sound of
crying strained but emphatic as if she
were filing a dispatch from a war zone
he started crying about 10 minutes ago
she reports but it seems to help if I
let her suck my finger
in the street outside the traffic honks
and roars people Mill around me passing
out into the London night
they are not only ignorant of the
strathorne region in which now I live
they are as remote from it as if it lay
on the other side of the world
should I come home I shout into the
receiver it's up to you comes the reply
after a pause I imagine she'll go to
sleep eventually
I promise to phone again in five minutes
time from the console Hall when I do the
news is bad I Rush deliriously home in a
taxi having bizarrely gone out for the
evening in order to visit phone boxes in
the West End
my mother-in-law's lot was no better she
came all the way to London to sit with
me my crying hungry child while I
telephoned her incessantly
thank you
how is it going back into the text 20
years later well I mean I've obviously
been thinking a lot today about
um
that relationship
um
to this
book that's
um still
seems to be alive it still seems and you
know that could
uh
that could be a sort of depressing idea
in a way that so little has changed
you know in some of some of the the sort
of problems of of uh motherhood that I I
write about
um but I don't think it really is that I
I think
I guess what I realized was that
you know I only was able to write this
book because I immediately had another
child and
it was that return to to the location
that
[Music]
um
was so astonishing to me because I
realized it had been
footprints in the snow it had melted the
whole memory the whole ability to
distinguish myself from that experience
it I only saw I only remembered it and
saw what what it was when I did it a
second time and and
um
and then I knew I had to instantly write
it down otherwise it it would go again
um so
I mean that to me is is
it just says something so fundamental
about
the difficulty of femininity and female
experience and the difficulty of writing
about it that that you know these um and
the feeling you know one has that there
are
there's nothing behind you there's you
know there's no history of these things
having been been consistently written
about there's no
ancestry there's you know there's no
feeling of of that you that you're kind
of continuing a traditional coming out
of somewhere that's been articulated you
know the the fact is
it you know it is impossible to write if
you have a baby and so nobody writes
about motherhood unless they can find
someone to look after the baby and I
mean that is self-evident but but in
terms of actually
you know the documenting these
fundamental
um
parts of life for others so that others
will know more about them and what was
it about this experience that you felt
hadn't been documented or
well I think I mean I do think that
there's
um
something in the nature of having a
child that um you know you think you are
the only person this has ever happened
to and I mean it has been I have noticed
and it has been sort of said to me on
occasion that each generation thinks
that nothing has been written about
motherhood but I mean the truth is that
very little has been written about
motherhood and
um
sorry I promise not to do that
um and you know when you think about the
the
world of you know my mother's Generation
Um where
you know so so it goes that the the sort
of chain of information had had kind of
broken down you know that mothers didn't
tell their daughters anymore how to you
know look after babies and uh and so the
experts the doctor spocks the you know
so
this stuff became written about but in
in a how to do it way
um which I suppose sets you up for
um
feelings of failure and feelings that
that you're not doing it right and so I
I think the subject changed probably
quite significantly in in
the kind of mid 20th century
um and and you know on before that
um
but I think the the situational
difficulty of
really really
recollecting what it's like what this
very first period is like you know the
fact that the same person has to have
the baby and write about it and I think
there's so many
um aspects of female experience that
that you know have have been like that
that you are both subjects and author
you know there is when you look at the
reaction when the book came out back
then and you sort of compare it to the I
would say praise and also admiration it
receives nowadays it feels as if it was
somehow you know written 20 years too
early or at least it you know it was it
was you know waiting for for us to catch
up with it
um but what do you feel changed in sort
of the way we are mothers but also talk
about motherhood since then
um I don't know that anything does
change I think it is absolutely true
that that that anything loses its power
to shock over time there's very very few
things that retain their power to shock
so time has an extraordinary ability to
to
um diffuse
um that
initial
um kind of
crash of you know
a cultural product into the established
way of of doing things and looking at
things
um
you know I think that that is a
um that's all very well uh to shock
people and to but but it's it
in a sense the the
and
the kind of incompatibility of those two
things the
the really
um
genuine attempt to to be accurate and
truthful about motherhood that I was you
know and it was hard to do it was hard
to write with two children under the age
of two you know that was not easy and uh
you're making yourself very vulnerable
by doing that and it's a you know and
you don't associate that effort because
it was an effort with
shock with uh violent anger towards you
with so so I think that is
um another thing that I discovered about
why
um
female experience has been hard to write
about because very often the you know
what you're trying to say you're trying
to describe unique
vulnerable exposed
episodes of being and becoming you know
in which you are not a victim exactly
but but you're you're very very
vulnerable and if people then attack
that not only are you
uh silenced but and I mean this was the
thing that I I hated the most about the
reception to a life's work and I used to
get a lot of letters
um
from all sorts of different kinds of
women including my mother who wrote to
me and said as though I was not her
daughter wrote to me and said oh your
book really reminded me of you know when
I had a baby me
um but I got a lot of letters from women
saying
that that the sight of me being
criticized for
truthfulness
discouraged them
from being truthful about their own
experiences and that they felt even more
isolated you know because some people
you know find motherhood difficult it is
difficult and and suddenly it being
proved that you're not allowed to say
that being proved very publicly was did
a form of damage that
you know I I it made me really really
angry and
um it was yeah far more than the damage
to me and did this response or even just
the experience of motherhood make you
start thinking about because Forum later
on in your writing becomes a very sort
of you know Central topic right how can
you write in a way that will prevent
truth from being you know mistaken as
rudeness for example
um was this something that you already
started thinking about at this point in
your writing life oh I mean absolutely
because
um you know there I was in the foothills
of an experience that I
realized I could not with with the novel
and you know and as it stood as As I
understood it and as I
practiced novel writing I could not put
this material in a novel and
uh without
falsifying it in some completely deadly
way
um and that was I suppose the real
beginning of me thinking okay so what so
what do I do I write two different kinds
of book I write and that is indeed what
I decided to do to to use this Memoir
form
which is just
um the most dangerous form to write in
it offers you absolutely no protection
um at all and
so I guess that in the end really really
led me to think why why can't
the novel adapt itself to
um
this whole other side of life what what
is wrong with it why can't it and it's
strange right because when you read a
life's work and even aftermath you know
you would the classic Memoir form is
full of details and surfaces you know
there'll be names there will be you know
street names and details and you sort of
already at this point developed a
technique where you are writing about
yourself but in a in a retracted way I
would say and still it caused anger why
is that
if I need the answer to that
I would possibly never have written it
luckily I don't seem to have kind of
learned
um
on that score
um oh I think uh one of the infuriating
[Music]
um
criticisms of the book because as you
say my my whole
you know I mean I wrote it
very much as I would write a novel so
using exactly the same Scruples and
discipline and and it was very much not
a kind of I'm going to get this off my
chest you know I'm just going to write
about myself
um because I can't be bothered to sort
of hide it
um
and the decision to to
just
um yeah withdraw the the identifiable
the clearly identifiable World
um so that a woman reading it or indeed
a man reading it could feel
um
that it was about them that that I'm not
saying oh my husband Martin you know
says or or giving locations or or I
wanted it to be
um
to retain that that
um
yeah that ability that you can own it as
as your own experience
um that universality I guess so when the
criticism was made that that I hadn't
given enough detail on this criticism
was very much made about aftermath as
well that I hadn't gone into the Gory
details you know I hadn't explained and
given
names and dates and
um that was really really frustrating
um because well you know the reason I
did this was to uh
I just give it independence from me and
and it was the opposite of of a sort of
exercising narcissism or self-obsession
or anything else you know I've been
reading Naples
um Enigma of arrivals oh well now in
fact if I have a pandemic book it's that
one really yeah okay so it's okay so we
need to talk about it because I I was
reading that and suddenly I started to
think about a life's work and I was
wondering why those two in a way became
connected and I think it relates to the
concert chapter actually that you were
reading before because
it seems as if you know just to explain
and I Paul wrote this book where he's
around middle aged and he starts to
remember he's living in an English
Village close to the Stonehenge and he
starts to sort of remember the time when
he immigrated from Trinidad to England
in 1950s and what that sort of that
experience did to him as a man and as a
writer and one of the things that I
think he really really describes is sort
of what happens to a person when you
immigrate which is that you become you
know chronically aware of the second
place you could say and I think that's
also one of the things I love the most
about your book is that you describe you
know you call it the curse of the
divided life you know that suddenly you
are not just in one place you're
dispersed you know from the Garden of
Eden in a way and I was wondering have
you what did you know what do mothers
and migrants have in common
that's it yeah
I think I mean what uh
and I pull identifies about that
experience is that you become
well it's it's this chronic state of
awareness you cannot stop your awareness
from from working and you
um you can't stop learning so you learn
every single thing you see so so and
you're not selecting particularly you're
just you know the whole
adaptation the whole effort of of trying
to belong means that you
um
over
you invest too much significance in
the things that you see whereas in fact
what's happening is you are in a
completely automatic state of of trying
to acquire knowledge trying to acquire
familiarity
um
and I mean that is something that in
terms of the prose
that it produces
um
I guess I found that such a moving
and devastating idea because I'm of my
own experience of being uprooted in
childhood and moving to England at the
age of eight and again you know not so
dramatically but but you know I had the
wrong I had an American accent I I had
no
sort of idea of how England worked or
you know in England was a much more sort
of
um divided well it's divided in a
different way now but um a very class
bound
critical judgmental society and and so
the you know Nai Paul's desperation to
fit in is actually partly a result of it
being England that that he moved to I
think
um
but you know what I recognized reading
that book was that
what I had felt to be something
um a sort of sacred quality to my
memories
um the the level of detail that I
remembered about
every single blade of grass in the
English Village that we moved to and I
could and for years I did used to to try
and make myself sleep in the period when
I had small children and being
constantly woken up and couldn't go back
to sleep I used to relive
the journey from our house in the back
of the car to my school and because I
knew it I knew it off by heart and I
just thought well you know by the time I
get there hopefully I'll be asleep but
it was quite a long journey and by the
time I've remembered every single
Hedgerow every field every you know
phone box and
um
and it really was only reading Nai Paul
that made me question why I had
remembered
these things that are meaningless that
have no value that that are not
and I treated them with such importance
because they were what happened to me
when I arrived in England and um so that
seems to me the the the thing that he
really amazingly
um renders
um and and the tragedy of that knowledge
um the the
the knowledge of arrival
um being yeah
you know another thing he talks about is
how making the move becoming an
immigrant kills imagination at least it
kills his imagination did you have a
similar experience when you became a
mother
or what does it do to you know I think I
sort of got divorced from the whole idea
of imagination possibly a bit before
that but but yeah I mean the the most
stunning thing for me
um
in terms of the experience of motherhood
but also uh trying to write
within or around that experience was
that um I couldn't you know the very
first
effect of it was that I could not read
so having had this baby I could no
longer read because I couldn't leave
reality
um I was not at all interested in living
in an imagined world and I needed
someone to be owning and verifying their
experience I could only read things that
were where the person said I and they
were talking about reality not not
um
you know
people in a made-up story or a narrative
and I think that was another reason why
it
it seemed to me that that was how I had
to write a life's work
um because that was all I wanted was for
someone to talk to me about this to
recognize what was happening and so I
think I probably wrote the book that I
wanted to read if you see what I mean
and aftermath
um which was published in 2012 I mean
you could describe it as a book
depicting your you know the breakup of
your marriage or the aftermath of that
you could also call it a book of
econoclasm because I think when when
reading it it seems that it's in this
book that one of the like major ideas of
your writing ever since is introduced
which is this idea of falling out of the
frame uh you know stopping to you know
ending the the marriage with plot
um can you say something about what the
end of your marriage did to your belief
in these you know image stories
um well I mean again it it
uh
there's the same relationship between I
mean lots of people get divorced and who
cares if I get divorced a million times
I mean it really doesn't matter it's not
it's not that that I particularly have
these things that I need to share with
it's more that I see these these
absolutely pivotal moments where where
huge changes in Awareness take place and
yeah for me the the change of awareness
that took place in in the
um
divorce experience was about belief and
it it's the loss of belief in reality
and
the realization of how much of living
relies on people being in a belief State
and if you're not in that state and you
don't believe you know everything from
love to even creativity to an extent to
political beliefs to
um
you know one of the things that that
I think makes depression so such a
powerful force in people's lives
potentially is that it is essentially a
loss of belief in In Living and
um you know that is a a depressing
experience if if you
um
I suppose if you I mean it almost
suggests that you really believe in
believing to the extent that if you
can't believe
you know it's like not believing in God
if you if you really really did believe
in God um that creates the state of
depression
um
so I think that uh
realization
that created aftermath
um
you know it was it was
you know I I suppose I I really mainly
um
am a writer of gendered experience and
what was so gendered in that divorce
moment was
this feeling that that
um all of the
the willingness the kind of biological
willingness that had been exacted for me
um
that this was this was just another
layer of belief about
what women were meant to do and what
female life was and that even if
um
you know having a child is in fact a a
sacred privilege and
um which which it is
um that that this power of being able to
do that had somehow been taken away from
women and and repackaged and resolded
them as a kind of
uh inferiority and a kind of slavery in
a sense and and
um
and that that it all runs on belief it
all runs on on
particular beliefs about what women feel
what they feel about children you know
you're not allowed to say that you feel
something different and and so I guess
sort of coming the second time around to
this
um
I I was a bit more severe I suppose in
aftermath than than you know a life's
work is is a funny book it's it's trying
to laugh at some of the things that that
I I did not feel like laughing
um the next time around you know one of
the harshest I think quotes in in in in
the book you write it looked like
feminism but was in fact male values my
parents among others well-meaning
bequeathed me the cross-dressing values
of my father and the anti-feminine
values of my mother I'm not a feminist
I'm a self-hating transvestite
what is it you're describing in the
value transaction that you're describing
in this quote well I mean the problem
with aftermath is it it was quoted uh I
hadn't realized how how much I'd left
the door open for you know the partial
quote such as I am not a feminist I
obviously am a feminist uh it's
um it needed some some good will you
know to be read probably that book and I
think I was describing something that is
um that may have changed now but but uh
that remains completely characteristic
of My Generation
Um of women
which is the generation whose mother's
lives and experiences are diametrically
opposite to ours and we then possibly
have female children whose experiences
are
a lot closer to ours
um so
you know to be the child of
old Womanhood of almost
pre-feminist Womanhood
um and and my experience was that that
you know my mother for a mother in in of
the type
um
kind of uses her
or kind of formulates
her powerlessness
in a uh as a
um form of pressure on
the daughter the new
um
so it's it's you know pressure to do
well pressure to do well at school and
to succeed and to come top and and with
no uh clue as to how
that's going to fit in with all the
other expectations that you will also be
the old kind of woman
um
you know a person my mother's positional
that generation of women you know there
were no female values that they could
pass on to us because those values were
um
the values of getting married at 21
changing your name being at home having
children one after the other not working
um that those were not values that they
they could
you know no woman of a you know child in
whatever it was 1970
was going to say to their child
don't worry about your maths don't worry
about learning you know because actually
you know when you leave school you'll
just be at home cooking so
um you know that
you had to
come up with a value system to go with
this education that your daughter was
receiving and and yeah and how did that
clash with the experience of becoming a
mother and you know becoming a family
um what in in for me yeah what class the
the the The Clash of these you know the
the sort of the the you could say the
male values that had been passed on and
then suddenly having to also be well I
mean I think that part of what what it
looked like what this what a life's
worth looked like was what it what would
be said if men had babies like if men
had babies they you know we would all
know a lot more about having babies I
think was the
um so I guess that I I described it
really from that
um
position a little bit of cultural
entitlement of of you know I'd written
already three novels they'd done well
I'd won prizes and so I I suppose I felt
without even thinking about it too much
that I had a platform to say things I
was allowed to write books if I wanted
to write a book about this I was allowed
to write a book about this little did I
know
um but so I think that that Clash was
um totally unconscious in me and
um
it was it only really revealed itself
in in what was then said when it turned
out that uh
part of having a child was becoming a
different kind of woman and a woman who
dissimulated a woman who said it's great
it's wonderful it's fantastic and some
of it is fantastic but but the the whole
social contract rested on
at a certain point
women beginning to lie about how things
were often for very good reasons and I
mean I've you know I've had a very very
complicated relationship over the years
with that dissimulation because
you know in in certain lights
it has looked
very much to me like courage and in
certain lights what I do has looked like
cowardice and
um you know being honest about things
compared to being brave about things for
instance
um you know I've thought about that a
lot but nonetheless it's
it is a
um
a a
real danger or a reality and a danger
that as you head into these very very
very
you know
uh structured history
parts of female experience you you know
you're not going to change it it's going
to change you and
um I guess my book was my last letter to
myself saying don't let it change you
you know stay Who You Are
and part of you know the I would say the
more not ecstatic books parts of the
book but the parts where you describe
living in the aftermath right like
trying to Define you know also starting
to recreate a home after having broke
break and breaking a home I mean these
are the parts where you also come to
terms with this new way you know idea of
having fallen out of the frame and one
of the ways you try to visualize to the
reader what this state of being in the
aftermath is is describing your history
teacher uh Mrs Lewis and and can you try
to describe you know what is it she sort
of taught you about living in the
aftermath
um
so
I mean that's sort of really the kind of
opening bit of the book which is trying
to
make the point that
um
that all human experiences have bear a
relationship to history and uh that I
mean this is you know Freud this is like
basic Freud
um which is that that human civilization
you know a human life
is is human the development of human
civilization in in a compact form
starting with you know
the ancient Greeks as infancy you know
and
um and I think my point was that
in these these relatively Uncharted
um areas of human experience that it's
hard to know which bit of History they
attach to and very often in the case of
divorce and and
really if I kind of
went back and thought about it again I
guess in the case of mother motherhood
too but I haven't thought about it in
that light
um that the links to history are really
really unclear
um and that's because
of History not not because of the
experience itself it's because these
experiences are are
um
I suppose
anti
um
anti-convention anti the the the
um the sort of rules the social rules
about you know how things work and and
um
you know particularly uh the idea of
um male power as a force in history and
I suppose what I could look back to was
this period of being taught history at
school where I had a teacher who was
much more interested in
um or for whatever reason we studied
that period in in the the things that
happened around the collapse of the
Roman Empire and the ways in which
different kinds of beliefs
Grassroots ways of of passing on
information or of of preaching or of
um you know had in the Dark Ages had had
their their time and and
um so it's really like kind of looking
through the the
sort of going through the mirror and
trying to see the other side of of you
know the Roman Empire say the other side
of these realities that are highly you
know that they're essentially sort of
patriarchal realities and trying to find
your history
on that other side of it
um of the thing that that people know
um
and and to me that was really
interesting and I think I've made my
point pretty successfully and it made
people absolutely curious so
um you know I we spoke
um in February 2020 and when when the
third part of your outline Trilogy had
just come out I interviewed you and I
was re you know I was listening to the
the recording the other day and I
realized that I
imposed a you know idea that the outline
Trilogy was a complete you know radical
break with everything you had ever done
before and I think in a way it was it
was just you know echoing you know the
the general response of of the trilogy
but when you look at aftermath it also
seems as if the the you know the trilogy
is really just not just but it is the
creative response to the insights you
had when you were writing the other book
yeah absolutely and and can you say
something about the relationship between
one like how you work yourself from one
book to another or to the next well I
mean sometimes
um
I mean I wouldn't
I don't think I would write
and if I did I wouldn't call it a memoir
but I you know I don't use the Memoir
form anymore
um partly because I tried to find
a way of resolving the two things and
you know that resolution was was
outlined
um
and
you know and yet you know the the
you know these these kinds of books and
in fact essays also have have this
function they they can they can be
really great places to work some stuff
out without quite feeling that you're
you you're taking up space in in the way
that a
creative or imaginative work would do
you know that needs a reason to exist
um it seems to me that an essay or a
memoir doesn't doesn't need a reason to
exist because it's its location is can
be tracked
to life and and
um
I think that more than anything that
feeling of
um
there needing to be a
um
a justification in terms of a location
for
the kinds of
the kind of book that I was interested
in writing
um you know I don't think anyone else
particularly cares about that I really
care about it I care that that uh
that you don't
by creating something just create sprawl
you know like suburbs around the city
that just because you want to you know
write a book you're just going to write
one and you're going to kind of plonk it
down without seeing how it how it what
it does to the landscape how it possibly
spoils other people's views or takes up
space that someone else could be using
and and
for me particularly that is that idea of
location is
um completely Central to saying anything
worthwhile about
female existence
um because
you know what is the place where is the
place of of women where is it where has
it been and as I said at the beginning
the powerful feeling that I really
thought about today of
footprints in the snow you know of what
that experience would have been if I had
not written it down and what so much of
of
biological living you know is
um unless the exhausted person who who
lives it can actually you know find a
location to to to put this stuff in
um
yeah so so I think the uh
the relationship between
um living and writing is
for me it's a tightrope it is such a
tightrope to walk and it's so easy to
spoil it it's so easy to get it wrong by
thinking that you know something is
about you when in fact it's completely
not about you and you are at its service
you know that's how I see it that I am
at the service of
um
you know the things the things that I
write and when you found the way to
locate you know Fey in the the Trinity
how what when we spoke the last time you
you described the trilogy as a book
consisting of prose photos
yeah that was what I wanted to get that
was what and I really remember
uh it took me a long time to work it out
and I
um in the end photography the idea of
Photography was because I was
I couldn't see how you would
um
capture
this this non-reality this lack because
it really was a life composed of you
know the post-divorce life uh that you
know people are becoming more and more
familiar with
um
it's not only the sort of pain of
dismantling it's it's just composed of
so many negatives of so many things you
no longer have uh and it's very hard to
make
create a work because essentially
creation is a positive thing out of all
those negatives
[Music]
so
I think that that was really where
um
the idea of of
essentially allow allowing uh making
making the big absence an absence of a
Storyteller
um which was also a
um
I guess my way of understanding
uh what
all of the things that I've sort of
troubled about and picked away at
narrative belief subjectivity all these
these things that I've I've sort of
found in you know in all these different
parts of life and I thought well
actually you know the biggest one is the
teller of the story is the you open a
book and someone's telling you who you
know who is that is that I mean it's
kind of maybe the writer but it's also
the writer is is believing in this this
omniscient narrator this this sort of
god-like figure who happens to like know
what's going on in other people's heads
and also knows what happened in the past
and the future and
in on the other side of the world and I
thought okay that if you can get rid of
that
um in and yeah photography suggested
itself to me because
the photographer and the photograph the
thing to be photographed are in a much
more
equal relationship you know the
photographer is a person waiting for an
opportunity and reality is the
opportunity and that that
way of perceiving of knowing that you
have to wait until reality arranges
itself in such a way that it gives out
the most possible information about what
it is about what is going on and okay so
you you think I need to take a photo of
Paris it's like you've got to have the
Eiffel Tower in there because then you
know that's really simple then everybody
will know it's Paris and and so that was
how I started to think was like how how
can you make a book write itself simply
by waiting and having the right the
right things in the picture so that you
don't need this narrator person and one
of the one of the people that Fame meets
it's an outline
um she meets a Greek publisher friend
they haven't met for several years
and
um he tells her that he lost you know
he's had a hard time his Publishing
House closed he has lost his belief in
the story of improvement and then he
says
it even affected infected the novel
though perhaps now the novel is
infecting us back again so that we can
expect of Our Lives what we have come to
expect of our books and and
it seems It's a paragraph where you also
really address the issue of of not just
progress but also the idea of
development in storytelling and what is
the problem with progress you know from
a novelistic point of view
[Music]
um
that it doesn't exist I guess and uh I
mean I think one of the things that
the pandemic has been so interesting uh
in the idea of progress and Improvement
the idea of the story rattling on you
know to to you know everyone more or
less the vast majority of people have
experienced a breakdown in reality a
breakdown of and so
I suppose a breakdown of what we call
reality which suddenly it's obvious was
a a yeah a narrative
um in which we believed
we had to you know we believed in in uh
meaningful developments
um we believed in Beginnings middles and
ends and and happy ends and
um
I think that's been a a massive
um
shock and a strain for a lot of people I
think it's probably created
um a lot of discouragement and
depression and people thinking well if
it was you know if it was just a story
you know what was the point if it could
all just stop and and I've heard that a
lot from people
um that they don't want
to believe in well they're struggling to
believe in reality again and to kind of
put their hearts into it and care about
things because it's really that it's
um
I suppose ways to to make you care about
the story of your own life it's so
interesting you use the word care
because I just read an essay by Adam
Phillips
um the English psychoanalytic and he
calls it the Cure of psychoanalysis and
I again thinking about your writing in
the text he tries to sort of Trail how
psychoanalysis has been thinking about
the idea of cure basically ever since
it's it's founding and and his problem
problematizes it because he says that
you know the idea of cure first of all
it adds you know it just adds to this
you know idea or image repertoire we
have in society because there is a you
know an assumption of what you know the
outcome will be and there is also
putting the psychoanalyst on a pedestal
where he or her knows what you know the
good life is and also what
um basically the the patient you know
what they dream of what they desire who
they are they know the patient better
and instead he quotes winikut and he
says that actually winika apparently
wrote that the word cure evolved from
the word care and it started to
degenerate in the 17th century when we
started becoming obsessed about health
and you know remedies instead of asking
them things getting better yeah so so so
he He suggests a reversal basically and
reading that it seemed that your writing
it was basically talking about the stuff
you're writing is talking about and I
wanted to ask you how psychoanalysis is
that something that has inspired you
influenced you so winokot was a huge
influence for me and particularly I mean
he I quote him a lot in in life's work
um or I mentally quote him if I don't
actually quote him I think I do actually
quote him quite a lot
um
I suppose the thing the time when that
really really uh
mattered to me
as well was in the period of writing
this book and it mattered not because I
had ever had psychoanalysis or was
intending to have it it was because of
it as a language system and what was
starkly apparent to me was that you were
allowed
in this language of psychoanalysis to
say the most extraordinary things about
motherhood and Winter Court says them so
you know the quote that I have in the
book typical winner he says the problem
is that the mother hates the baby before
the baby knows that that it's he is
capable of being hated okay that's a
classic winacot line and winokot was a
you know revered child
um I mean he was in in terms of
um
you know English British Society at a
particular moment he really built you
know sort of big parts of what was good
about that in terms of you know
understanding
um children and
um so I was like okay this is wild like
you can you really can say anything
um and I think that was where I
missed
the warning signs in in
this book that maybe you know not
everybody had read winter and um or
um so I think my my real uh
sort of relish for psychoanalytic
writing started there and then I read
Freud you know
endlessly and um young and I mean
Young's not so fun to read but
um and then you know lots of things
Alice Miller you know good good stuff
about how how to treat other people how
to treat children how to you know so so
it's these um
writings that go so much further into
uh the
entrails of living than a novel ever
does ever even never read a a novelist
really really morally
grappling with
[Music]
true human impulses other than
Dostoevsky he's he's probably the only
one who who would really dare to to
Grapple in that way
um with with not in a
caring about and the main point about
psychoanalysis is it is incompatible
with religion and and that it's you know
it's absolute strength is it is not
it isn't written with an unconscious
judeo-christian
the concept of reality it you know that
is the radical thing about it it's
looking at the world without that and
you know Freud Freud's completely
hilarious sort of attempt to understand
what religious feeling is when he says
well sometimes I I guess an oceanic
feeling is it that but then he goes no
in fact I just I can explain the oceanic
feeling you know which is a desire for
religion or a desire that my life be
meaningful and that I correspond with
you know some something greater than
myself
um so I mean you know these things
especially if you've grown up oppressed
by completely
pointless authoritarian uses of you know
religious rules which I was
um
you know that is a great liberation
the in the Adam Phillips text he quotes
a letter that Freud sent to Young where
he's he writes to him
um I need to stop thinking about curing
people and just
think about you know learning something
and earning money yes
and but but but but going back to to
them and the you know the big Insight of
how reality is constructed I mean
reading your books it's one long
exercise in trying to get used to this
idea but because your books aren't
self-help books you don't really you
know tell the reader what they should do
with that but but if we you know go back
to to not your own life but but you're
thinking life how does one learn to cope
with that realization because as you
said before many people
experience that for the first time
during Corona
um about this idea that that's a loss of
belief in reality
um
uh
yeah I don't know I don't know what the
answer to that is I think
um
it's something that I
kind of
you know it's become completely Central
to the way that I think about the world
and and
um I think I get a feeling sometimes
that
there's a sense in in you know my
readership to the extent that I have one
or people
sort of critiquing my work favorably
there's a little sense of
let her deal with it let's just let her
deal with that problem of you know
um
so I don't know I don't know whether
it's a
um
something that people are relieved to
have pointed out for them
um so that they don't have to
um worry too much about it because in
fact there's no uh
there's not an awful lot you can do with
um
belief uh it's loss it's gain its
presence
um you know one of the most infuriating
things I am occasionally infuriated by
um
this thing that I do which is writing
things and and other people reading them
and then not understanding them which
you know I don't know why that but but
you know the thing that's been said to
me so much about second place is oh
but you said you didn't believe in
novels and fiction and stories anymore
and and you know here it is this is a
novel with a story and and
um
you know that that
you know I'm not proselytizing for
anything I'm I'm not I'm just trying to
to help myself and anyone else who
cares
um to have more
power of self I suppose more control
over
existence and Destiny of more control
over individuality because for me
individuality is the uh single and only
value and
um
is the one
Thing by which you can always navigate
and we give it up so easily
um and then you know my I suppose the
story that I've told across so many
books is is almost a
sort of a bit of an odyssey of giving it
up
into these various structures
and then knowing that you have to get it
back and you have to break up it all in
order to get that thing back and and
resume your your rightful you know place
on on on the road there is a sentence in
in second place that
moves me very much
um why do we live so painfully in our
fiction why do we suffer so from the
things we ourselves have invented and
the main character in the book M you
call her what are the fictions she is
living with and suffer from
I will does she said she's quite late in
life at this point so you're not late in
life but I mean she's you know the the
I guess the sort of
reality well not really reality but the
the
um terrain of living that I really
wanted to write about but absolutely
could not see how I was going to do it
um
was this idea of
um
a sort of female extension Beyond its
own beyond the purposes of femininity
and
you know the question of what which was
a question I asked myself at a certain
point and that's usually where I start a
thinking and writing process where I
think okay well I'm doing this and is
anybody else doing it and
um so my question was what am I for like
why what
why do I continue to exist when you know
my biological purpose is done and yet
I'm given this is it so that I can just
wait for my children to have children
then I have to go and look after those
or is that what sort of biology is up to
here
um but you know not really and and this
this post post everything feeling
um
that didn't have any didn't seem to have
any
structure or any features or or it just
seemed to be in terms of how women exist
in the culture in in later phases of
life it seems just to be sort of lots of
women alone kind of wandering around
trying to sort of give it a meaning or
structure and sort of make the best of
it and and
um you know there's no organized
sort of midlife crisis like there is for
men where you get a motorbike and you
have an affair with a 20 year old or
whatever you know there's just none of
none of that you know material and
[Music]
um
you know the reason I fell with glad
cries on on
um the the structure for second place
was that that it it precisely
married these two things that I
was really wondering about one is that
the woman wandering around in in sort of
later middle age really can
look back on her femininity and think
you know what was that for and and I
have been made use of I have been made
use of as a woman and that you know I I
talk about belief States I believed you
know like a good girl I believed all
along in love in loving my children and
having them in you know
uh and I think at a certain point it can
really seem that you have been exploited
um
without you know and you've like said
okay you've sort of gone along with it
and at exactly the same moment
um I really think of revaluing of male
entitlement and privilege
um can occur and that what I wanted was
the woman looking giving the backward
glance
and suddenly seeing it all in a
different light
seeing at the same time that part of
what has sustained her in her possible
exploitation or her is Art is the the
ability to read to listen to music to
look at paintings and feel meaning
being given to her life feel that she
has at least in some sense
been understood been expressed by
artists and art and
meanwhile the artist the male you know
and she invites to yes but I mean the
figure of the artist which is sort of
where I started was like you know how is
it that we
uh you know that person that male
cultural icon is
um
it's so badly behaved it's so selfish
it's so uh you know the stories and I
mean I started to think about this
because I wrote a something like Lucy
and Freud for the New York Times in that
light as like you know because really
the question is oh you know should we
stop looking at paintings by these
people I mean you know is it going to
come to that and you know I don't know
maybe it should
um but but the yeah the the the
abandoning of children the abusing of
women the the complete Indulgence in you
know every desire and and whim
um and and that's
you know if you look at these two people
the Lucian Freud person and the the
woman going oh what was all that about
you have
quite an interesting uh you know that
woman can say to that man do you
consider that I am a woman uh do you
know here I am sort of post everything
post biology
um in your eyes am I still a woman and
uh that was the situation
that I wanted to really get out and and
in the case of
foreign
and her artists you know that was the
situation that she endlessly endlessly
put herself in and and when you put the
book away you really do have the feeling
that you know men have freedom and women
have faiths in a strange way
um but but do you
I mean you addressed this topic before
you know if again when I picked up this
book I thought oh this is the first time
you're addressing the topic of aging and
what it means to be a female body aging
but actually in a life's work there's
this short paragraph where you talk
about Natasha from War and Peace uh told
stories yeah and and and the the idea of
how she's sort of written out of the
book and when you start thinking about
it and the fate of women in fiction is
is you know gruesome and and quite
repetitive because you also have Anna
Karenina with Kitty the same thing
happens it's always something with their
eyes this whole story was very sad when
women became stopped being romantic
heroines yeah they they they they have
like they're in the book for a while and
there they become secondary characters
and that's also what seems so radical I
would even say in the project you impact
done now with this book and that you
might continue I don't know but but
when you become a mother to an infant
you're still the one telling the story
but the female figure that you are
trying to describe now is someone who
doesn't yeah yeah who doesn't even have
a part in the story
um and
I mean I guess
there was so much I
wanted to say about that
um and yet it's so it's another of those
things that's composed of absences
um it's it's a very you know without
reattaching
everything to life again
um it's it's hard to get at it and I
didn't you know these things are lost in
in being
um attached to life in in the sort of
fundamentally Bourgeois way that a novel
has to function it has to put its
characters in the world and and you know
there you get distance and
um and okay what you know a character
can function as a as a as Dickens still
functions very well as a type you know
as a way of understanding a type in
society or possibly even a
um
a phase of life or or but you know not
these kinds of phases of Life they're
they're so Universal and yet so hidden
um and so unarticulated
um that it's you know it is a very
difficult business to to
represent them without personalizing
them and and what do you feel you
haven't
gotten onto the page of that experience
in this book
um
well I don't know because I don't know
how it um it's interesting because I I
decided at a very late moment to which
is what I always do when I finish a book
I think no one's going to understand it
and in this case I thought they're
really not going to understand it and I
put a note and afterward a little
paragraph saying that the book is
indebted to this other book and I'm
I do wonder whether I was wrong in doing
that because if that hadn't
I mean every single conversation I've
had about this book it always has to go
through the question of Mabel Dodge
Luhan who in fact you know the book is
actually not really
anything to do with her and and it it
takes her it just took her ability to to
make an example of something
um which is the kind of thing Writers Do
all the time and they don't tell anybody
about it so so
um
yeah I wonder whether actually if I had
not
um disclosed that origin whether in fact
the strangeness of the book would be
doing a lot more work and people would
be going you know would be made to think
about it in well they would just Supply
a lot more of the the filling in and
thinking because you know there's one
thing I know about writing and reading
it's literally the minute you give
people a fact it's like when there's a
TV on in a room and you know you can't
stop watching it it's a magnet and the
minute you give someone a fact they're
magnetized for obvious reasons by that
and it starts to it just conditions the
way everybody
um
then understands reality do you
sometimes consider revising your work
because one thing is regretting
decisions made but you know painters
some painters you know
spend a lot of time we you know either
yeah creating yeah could you imagine
removing this information for you oh
that wouldn't be revising that is it's
going out yeah I think I think it will
go for the paperback I don't think I'll
um I'll have it in there I'll
I'll let that Rabbit Run
um give it an opportunity to yes
possibly mystify the book a bit more um
because in fact the book is mysterious
and the Mystery is not explained by
Mabel Dodge Luhan
um so yeah it's interesting you you
mentioned Lucian Freud before and I
actually found a quote from a text you
wrote not about him but about Celia Paul
and Cecily Brown and and and well and
about him yeah and also about him
um I'm just going to quote from from the
text you ask can a woman artist however
talented however disciplined ever attain
a fundamental freedom from the fact of
her own Womanhood must the politics of
femininity invariably be accounted for
whether By determinedly ignoring them or
by deliberately confronting them the
later is a fateful choice that can shape
an artist's life and work but as the
former the avoidance of oneself as a
female subject inevitably compromise the
expressive Act how do you answer this
question at this point in well in your
life I went it is the fork in the road
um I went one way you know at a certain
point in my life and and a lot of other
people went the other way and
um
I I don't know what the final adding up
of that is
um I don't know whether the the women
writers who who have not solid
themselves with you know all of these
difficulties and and
um
whether in the end it is you know I
don't know the answer to the question is
it do do you compromise
um
you know your gift your talent uh in the
end if you
um and I mean it's a very
it's it's it's a question for for
Outsiders it's a question for women and
you know others like nypool like
Lawrence
um
how much do they
try to they ditch you know
unpleasant aspects of of who they are in
order to to
to try and join the conversation and fit
in with with the men
um
yeah I suppose I believe that that
[Music]
um
you particularly in writing more in
writing than in any other art I think
um the the life you live
uh
uh is
if you don't live right you will lose
your
um ability to to write and living
wrongly and in fact this probably is
true of visual artists too
um
and there's so many ways of doing that
once your work is out in the world you
know caring too much of about the
surface of it about you know the fact
that it is out in the world
um but I think for women
um
you know there is a
it is or you know and it's now becoming
a question in identity generally which
is just because I'm this thing does that
mean that I have to devote you know my
entire writing career to it you know
aren't I free I free to just talk about
whatever I want to and and
um
no you know my answer is no
um my answer is you you unfortunately
you uh you are born into you were born
into something that that um has some
injustice to attached to it and
um you have to as you would if you walk
past it in the street you have to do
something about it
before we finish you are going to read
but before that I promise to say that
after the talk
um you'll be signing books outside and
you can all go and buy a copy of the
book and have a signature
um so do you want to read I'm just going
to read the first couple of pages of um
this very strange book
I am in fact very fonder
um
I once told you Jeffers about the time I
met the devil on a train leaving Paris
and about how after that meeting the
evil that usually Lies undisturbed
Beneath the surface of things rose up
and disgorged itself over every part of
life
it was like a contamination Jeffers it
got into everything and turned it bad
I don't think I realized how many parts
of life there were until each one of
them began to release its capacity for
Badness
I know you've always known about such
things and have written about them even
when others didn't want to hear and
found it tiresome to dwell on what was
wicked and wrong
nonetheless you carried on building a
shelter for people to use when things
went wrong for them too and go wrong
they always do
fear is a habit like any other and
habits kill what is essential in
ourselves
I was left with the kind of Blackness
Jeffers from those years of being afraid
I kept on expecting things to jump out
at me I kept expecting to hear the same
laughter of that devil I heard the day
he pursued me up and down the train
it was the middle of the afternoon and
very hot and the carriages were crowded
enough that I thought I could get away
from him merely by going and sitting
somewhere else
but every time I moved my seat a few
minutes later there he'd be
sprawled across from me and laughing
what did he want with me Jeffers he was
horrible in appearance yellow and
Bloated with bloodshot bile colored eyes
and when he laughed he showed dirty
teeth with one entirely black tooth
right in the middle
he bought earrings and dandyish clothes
that were soiled with the sweat that
came pouring out of him the more he
sweated the more he laughed and he
gabbled non-stop in a language I
couldn't recognize but it was loud and
full of what sounded like curses you
couldn't exactly ignore it and yet that
was precisely what all the people in the
carriages did
he had a girl with him Jeffers a
shocking little creature nothing more
than a painted child who was barely
clothed she sat on his knee with parted
lips and the soft gaze of a dumb animal
while he fondled her and nobody said or
did a thing to stop him
of all the people on that train was it
true that the one most likely to try was
me
perhaps he followed me up and down the
carriages to tempt me into it but it was
not my own country I was only passing
through going back to a home I thought
of with secret dread and it didn't seem
up to me to stop him
it's so easy to think you don't matter
all that much at the very moment when
your moral duty as a self is most
exposed
if I'd stood up to him perhaps all the
things that happened afterwards wouldn't
have occurred
but for once I thought let someone else
do it
and that is how we lose control over our
own destinies
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]